hey youtubers is Charlie and this week
on Game of Thrones so many sad things
happened this face was my face after it
was all said and done they probably
wanted to skip last week just to give us
a break from all the WTF moments before
we tried to mentally unpack everything
quick shut up for the giveaway just as a
way to say thank you to all you guys for
being awesome I'm giving away an Amazon
gift card all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment below on
this video I'm also willing to send out
some digital hugs to given everything
that happened so let's do top five
moments first then I'll do my review and
then I'll circle back around for any big
plot points that we need to remember but
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet but here we go
number five Miss Anne died and grey worm
shipping this may have been one of the
only happy moments from the episode the
reason it really ends up being
depressing though is they'll never be
able to fully consummate their
relationship I'd argue that that
shouldn't stop them from pursuing a
companionship that goes beyond simple
friendship it's just gonna make things
very very difficult based on the way
that they left things it seems like miss
and I is really willing to pursue
something it's great worm that's
reluctant but given enough time I think
that he'll come around the thing that
really struck me about them is that of
all the relationships we saw in the
episode theirs was the only one that you
feel good about like Roose and Ramsay
Littlefinger and Sansa they all just
creeped me out
number four Sansa learns to lie did you
see how she dyed her hair black in that
last scene and they were just giving
each other creepy looks big flashing
warning lights going on everywhere the
whole Vale story this week seems like it
was more about Sansa shedding the rest
of her innocence or at least most of it
like she's slowly suffocating the sweet
summer child inside of her as pervy as
Littlefinger seems with those long gazes
his interest in her isn't just sexual
it's more like he's taking pleasure in
watching her learn to play the game I'm
really interested to see where they take
our character from here it seems like
Sansa on the show has caught up to book
Sansa in terms of plot like when we get
to season five the show will be ahead of
the books at least for Santa's character
number three sir Jorah is exiled poor
sir Jorah he brought it on himself that
external shot of the city when he was
writing out of town was so sad it looked
like it was lifted straight out of a
really depressing western
and it almost made things worse that
Daenerys didn't shout at him like the
moment was so upsetting that she was
just screaming internally just like all
of us were screaming internally during
the entire episode but I was confused by
was the royal pardon he clearly got a
copy of it way back in season one
so was this a new copy the seal of the
hand of the King was on it so I'm
assuming that what Jorah said was
correct Tywin Lannister was trying to
divide Daenerys inner circle to keep
them busy I really hope this isn't the
last we've seen of Sir Jorah this season
but I think he's going to be on Daenerys
his [ __ ] list for a long time so if we
do see him he'll be on his own and
number 2 Ramsay snow becomes Ramsay
Bolton this was one of the most twisted
victory moments I've seen this season
like when something really awful gets
celebrated like dwarf jousting or when a
big villain wins a victory like the red
wedding the show even changes the music
to this really uncomfortable tune so
that internally you kind of know not to
cheer real quick though no judging no
judging here on this channel did you
cheer whenever Roose made Ramsay Bolton
my brain actually melted just a little
bit when that happened if there was any
doubt that something terrible just
happened there was that line from Ramsay
telling reek he'd be giving him a bath
later yuck that's actually like the best
word to describe that whole part of the
story the flayed man was actually just a
visual representation of that in fact if
any of your friends ever asked you to
explain Ramsay just show them a
screencap of this flayed man that will
tell them everything they need to know I
actually had a hard time telling just
because the video I was watching was
kind of low res but that keep off in the
distance I thought it was moat Cailin
they were marching to but because ruse
had just gotten done talking about this
big North speech I kind of thought it
might be Winterfell because when you
think of the north you think of
Winterfell and my number one WTF moment
no surprises here Oberyn Martell vs. the
mountain so many things to unpack here
let's just start with the fight itself
Pedro Pascal looked like he was doing
all the stunts what they did with the
fight choreography was so much better
than what I had imagined and even though
Oberyn did get his skull crushed in he
did beat the mountain
did get a measure of revenge he just
waited too long to finish him off that
wicked-looking Paikea his was so awesome
to here's an up close shot of what that
spear tip looked like he rammed that
through the mountains chest severed his
hamstring and landed a few other really
deep slice cuts I actually did a video
earlier today kind of explaining the
mountains armor he's basically like a
walking fortress he has like three
different layers of armor so the only
way to land a blow is in one of the gaps
in the plates on that subject - even if
Oberyn had been wearing a helmet the
mountain still would have been able to
crush his head through it so don't feel
like ignoring Tyrion had anything to do
with him dying I totally should not have
been surprised when they showed that
wide shot of his smashed body of all the
things that the show has done this
season I still think that Joffrey's you
know up-close purple face is worse at
the end of the season I'll have to do a
breakdown of all the most vomit-inducing
scenes like a montage of epic WTF for
all the people that have read the books
try to be careful with spoilers in the
comments about what happens after the
fight just because the mountain as far
as we know is just collapsed right
they're lying we don't really know what
its final fate is he's kind of floating
around in the ether right now this is
going to be remembered is one of the
best fight scenes the show has ever done
I think the show is going to have a
really hard time topping it either this
season or next season or at some point
in the future but now it's your turn let
me know in the comments below what was
your favorite moment and try to describe
the face you made whenever the mountain
squished oberyn's head overall I felt
like this was a b-plus episode with an
A+ fight attached at the end usually the
different scenes all over the world
connect on a really deep level but this
week felt a little disconnected in the
show's defense that might have been the
point though I think the secret to
decoding the episode is in decoding
Orson Lannister smashing his beetles I
tried to pay special attention to Tyrion
speech it was really really long
duration is actually a really good
indicator of how important the show
owners think something is thus listening
to Tyrion decode Orson was probably one
of the most important things in the
episode I think they were just trying to
convey the idea of futility like no one
understands why they're killing all
these people either in the war of the
five kings or just on a general level
the speech didn't really end with any
kind of resolution they didn't
answer the question about what it all
means so I think we're headed for just a
lot more senseless killing before the
end of the season but let me know what
do you think that that speech about the
Beatles means and what it represents for
the future really the only hanging
threads at the end of the episode are
Tyrion and Arya Tywin sentence Tyrion to
death so we need to think about what's
going to happen to him in the final two
hours of the season please book readers
if you're going to post photos be sure
to use spoiler tags and just hit enter
four or five times before leaving a
comment as for Arya it didn't make it
into my top 5 moments but her reaction
to learning that her aunt Lysa died was
amazing I think she was just laughing
because it was one of the most awful
things that could have happened
it's like Murphy's Law anything that can
go wrong will go wrong and she's just
laughing at the universe I actually
liked arias reaction to her situation
more than Tyrion Stu his I guess you
could kind of say that he's subject to
Murphy's Law too right now the things
I'm looking forward to most on the show
are the wildling attack on the Nights
Watch re in the Hound there's really
only a couple more places for them to go
after the Vale and finding out what the
Martel's are going to do once they learn
Oberyn is dead so like usual my Q&A will
post tomorrow be sure to subscribe to
get it I'll try to post it a little bit
earlier than normal
you can actually click right here to get
it all add the annotation as soon as I
post it and you can click here to learn
about my top 10 fighters on Game of
Thrones thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
you